When we just ran the Pitch Perfect app,
we saw that the segue is getting cold.
But that the play sounds view
controller still does not know the path
of the recorded audio.
When the segue is called,
there's a function that's triggered on
the existing view controller
to help it prepare for segue.
It is called, prepare for seg.
Remember this is on the existing view
controller, not the one we're going to.
So let's open up record
sounds view controller and
scroll towards the bottom.
If we start typing prepare, we see that
auto complete fills our prepare for
interface or prepare for segue.
Let's choose prepare for segue.
In the prepare for segue function,
we need to add a few lines of code.
First we check that this
is a segue that we want.
That it has the stop
recording identifier.
Then we can grab the play
sounds view controller
from the handy property
destination view controller.
Because this property is of
type UI view controller, but
we know it's a play sounds view
controller, we can downcast it.
As you see here with the as!
Next we grab the sender,
which is where we pack URL.
And finally,
we set the record audio property of the
play sound view controller to that URL.
Now, the play sounds view controller is
receiving the recorded audio file URL
and is set for playback.